uh i led off with it it's got to be an
interesting moment a lot of your friends
probably bring this up and family
members you created taxi magic
which if my memory serves me correct was
a way to get a taxi
and have it dispatched uh sounds very
familiar to me
and you did that back in 2007 which was
a couple of years before uber existed
correct
yeah we uh started taxi magic in
february of 2007
and um you know launched it uh as a
product
first on the east coast and then in san
francisco as well
you could book a taxi to come to you
through your phone
at this point it was a blackberry and an
uh you know palm device windows mobile
iphone did not yet exist
and then you could also pay for the taxi
through the phone as well
all connected to the dispatch systems at
the taxi fleets
i didn't realize you also had payments
because that was uber's uh and lyft's
big innovation as well
but you did it with taxis not with
lincoln town cars take me back to that
decision
to do taxis and not lincoln town cars
yeah so we um
i mean we actually did lincoln town cars
in new york but the thinking was we
wanted to appeal to the broadest segment
of
population and taxes made a lot of sense
the
concept for the business came out of b2b
use actually it was for business
travelers first
and they would not want black cars right
the travel manager would want to limit
what you spend and the idea was to kind
of have you do
taxis rather than black cars that was
kind of part of the concept
um and you know we we came up with a lot
of great tech and
my co-founder and now my co-series shift
um toby russell calls it the
you know netscape of the automotive
on-demand space because we came up with
a product and then obviously others won
which is fine we still learned a ton and
it was a really great experience but
for us the really big uh kind of
challenge came when
um lehman brothers went under actually
because
we lehmann brothers was gonna be our
first
uh new york customer uh with all the
black cars in new york kind of using our
tech to
do that pick up from the bank and take
you home at night um
product which was very popular you know
you back in the day a lot of
black cars were circling of the banks to
pick people up
yeah if you lived in new york you saw
down from any
major high price building class a office
space whether it was goldman sachs or
you know um a famous law firm or sherman
sterling or something there would just
be
tons and tons of lincoln town cars
circling to take people home for a
hundred bucks a pop to brooklyn
yeah that's exactly right and so we're
gonna be managing that for
for lehman brothers and enough like
literally we signed the contract to do
that about
two weeks before they went under um so
that really kind of messed the
new york plan up but we were gonna do
black cars in a much more aggressive way
in addition to taxis in new york in
particular
um but you know i think the really big
problem for us was the fact that
we never gave a product away for free um
like the the team at its core and in
particular our co-founder
um tom de pascuale who's a super amazing
uh businessman
but he had done a bunch of enterprise
businesses and so he really believed the
notion that hey you got to charge
um for everything right off the bat and
that was a mistake that we made we
should have gone freemium
offered the product for free gotten a
bunch of users and then
kind of so that throttled your growth
because people didn't even know you
existed and the only way they would know
you existed if they gave you money so
there's a huge lesson learned